date night out for for you I'm by the
way we've been like we've been let into
all the process from your life oh my god
you saw that yeah what's the song yeah
that was so fun man like chickens come
home to roost I didn't realize that
actually be confronted with yes yeah
we've been I've been tweeting all day
it's making him crazy and it's not
really making you thought it was made
did it make you crazy I think it's very
endearing I think she's got a future in
photojournalism you look at the stunning
clarity of each photo a picture's worth
a thousand words but these photos are
words worth several several hundred not
quite a thousand
now what about Jack has Jack seen the
movie yet Jack directed the movie yeah a
lot of people don't know that he's the
ghost
director and writer of guardians the
galaxy had only four years old it's
quite an accomplishment he hasn't seen
the movie yet he's seen the first one in
fact he's at home right now this
babysitter watching the first one yeah
yeah yeah did you get it did you react
to it like what are some of his favorite
things about he totally gets it I mean
he's you know is he's four and a half
four and two thirds he'll tell you but
um he's he's a huge movie fan and a
Marvel fan and he gets it he sits
through movies he loves the story and
you know we're just mom and dad at home
but on TV we get to be you know we get
to be heroes and and and we're actors
and and and it's like he don't think he
gets it I don't know I guess he gets it
it's his world he's growing up in the
circus whether he likes it or not
you know he's got two very grounded
parents in the circus so I mean it's
gonna be great for him but a lot of
people obviously still like beyond
excited about this movie how about you
how proud of you this guy and about this
moment I I'm in awe on the way here I
was so much more nervous than Chris was
I feel the I feel this incredible you
know shift in my life I love it that
Chris is I vote I felt like I've always
known he's a brilliant actor and and now
acting like the rest of the world is
getting to see that I'm so thrilled
about this movie I had the pleasure of
seeing it and it's so good it's so good
that I woke up thinking about it